[Musique]
c'est le fait d'avoir trouvé ce portrait
qui a suscité mon intérêt pour les
afro-américains en union soviétique dans
les années 1930
j'ai une maîtrise en littérature russe
je parle russe et j'ai vécu en russie à
la fin des années 1980 mais le fait
d'avoir trouvé ce portrait m'a troublé
comment se faisait-il que je n'étais pas
au courant je ne savais pas du tout que
beaucoup d'afro américains était parti
en russie dans les années 30 il dans les
années 1920 1930
plusieurs centaines d'afro américains
sont partis vivre en union soviétique et
beaucoup de leurs descendants vivent
encore en russie
[Musique]
il n'y a pas de sens rue sans moi mais
pour répondre à votre question sur la
façon dont je m'identifie je le dirai
sans la moindre hésitation
bien sûr je suis russe les russes que je
rencontre ici nous perçoivent d'abord
comme une étrangère
mais quand je leur parle russe ils
disent mais attends attends tu es des
nôtres
tu es russes dans leur pays les
afro-américains faisait face au racisme
et à une absence totale de perspective
une fois mon père à regarder une femme
blanche par la fenêtre
à l'époque on n'avait pas le droit de
regarder les femmes blanches
alors ils avaient peur d'être lynché
lynch alors ils ont décidé de tout
laisser derrière eux et de commencer une
nouvelle vie dans un pays dont il ne
savait presque rien certains afro
américains qui sont allés en union
soviétique dans les années 1930 aux
connu un grand succès je suis devenu
extrêmement populaire grâce à ce film
quel genre de voiture avez-vous nous
avons vu votre belle voiture en arrivant
une jaguar et maintenant près de cent
ans plus tard l'histoire se répète mon
arrière grand père georges stein ce
match est venu enrichi probablement une
pire des moments
je me suis dit pourquoi pas moi wallace
et si je venais ici
[Musique]
non
ma grand mère s'appelait berka bialik et
le nom de mon grand père était olivier
golden mon grand-père était afro
américains fils d'esclave
à l'époque la décision de ma grand-mère
de se marier et le lier son destin à
quelqu'un comme lui pour une fille
blanche épousé un américain noir c'était
du jamais vu donc mes grands-parents
penser qu'il n'avait pas d'avenir en
tant que couple en amérique
les couples mixtes était une vraie
question aux états unis principalement
en raison des lois jim crow et d'une
grande haine vis-à-vis des
afro-américains cette idée de se mettre
en couple avec un noir et c'est
absolument inacceptable pour de nombreux
blancs c'était illégal dont beaucoup d
pourquoi mes parents ont choisi l'union
soviétique
non et bien tout d'abord ils étaient
séduits par les idées communistes et
socialistes sont là et ensuite les dés
de vivre dans un pays qui ne
connaissaient pas le racisme les
attirait beaucoup moins c'était un
nouveau pays en train d'être façonné et
par sa constitution il s'opposait à
toute sorte de discrimination raciale
sexuelle en arrière grand père georges
times et de smithfield en virginie match
à niort
[Musique]
et ils se retrouvaient en russie de
manière très particulière il a su
décrocher un contrat étonnant avec le
ministère soviétique de l'agriculture
chat il est monté sur un bateau et s'est
retrouvé en union soviétique dans les
années 1930
il est important de se rappeler que
c'était la période de la grande
dépression
c'était aussi une période où le
gouvernement soviétique recruter
massivement de personnes ayant des
compétences techniques
ils avaient un diplôme universitaire en
agriculture et en amérique
il n'y avait pas d'opportunités de
carrière pas d'emploi il y avait
beaucoup de discrimination alors que
pouvait-il faire il est allé dans un
pays dont il ne connaissait pratiquement
rien les actualités présenter la russie
comme un pays communiste
à quoi bon y aller georges times avait
un rêve
il a trouvé une solution end et il est
rentré dans l'histoire certains afro
américains qui sont allés en union
soviétique dans les années 1930 ont
connu un grand succès par exemple l'oeil
de paterson et son fils james paterson
james paterson est devenu célèbre en
étant le bébé du film le cirque
[Musique]
le cirque est un film qui a une histoire
extraordinaire
on dit que c'était le film préféré de
staline dans la scène d'ouverture nous
voyons une femme qui essaie d'échapper à
une foule en colère
la menaçant et lui jetant des pierres et
on réalise que ce paquet qu'elle porte
et son enfant noir dans la scène finale
l'imprésario allemand révèle la vérité
au public dans le cirque en expliquant
qu'elle a un enfant noir et bien sûr le
public soviétique a réagi de la façon
suivante on se fiche bien qu'ils soient
violés ou à pois et ensuite chacun prend
le p'tit djimy dans ses bras et tout le
monde lui chante une berceuse dans
toutes les langues de l'union soviétique
[Musique]
certes le film ne pouvait pas être plus
propagandiste mais à l'époque il était
incroyablement populaire même la chanson
du film vaste et mon pays est devenu une
sorte d'hymne de l'union soviétique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
berghoff est certainement juste de dire
que l'union soviétique était au premier
plan dans la lutte contre le racisme au
niveau gouvernemental
ce petit garçon noir qui a joué dans le
film le cirque a maintenant 87 ans il
est né et a grandi en union soviétique
il a servi dans la marine en tant que
sous mariniers ensuite il est devenu
écrivain et il a écrit des nouvelles au
début des années 1990 après
l'effondrement de l'union soviétique
jim paterson s'est installé aux états
unis dans la patrie de son père lloyd
paterson pour traduire des ouvrages en
anglais
il vit maintenant seul dans un logement
social à washington ce film m'a fait je
suis devenu extrêmement populaire grâce
à ce film
dahlin me connaissait parce qu'il aimait
ce film le cirque alors que je marchais
devant les gradins avec les autres
enfants
tallinn m'a reconnu les autres étaient
blancs et moi j'étais un peu bronzé le
père de jim leape paterson comme
beaucoup d'autres à foix américain a
déménagé en urss parce qu'il a décroché
un contrat mais il a tellement aimé le
pays qu'il y est resté et a créé une
famille
à moscou il fréquente et des cercles où
il n'aurait jamais été admis aux états
unis il avait une femme et trois fils
une carrière il était occupé tout le
temps sa femme s'appelait verra are a
lot va c'était une designer assez connu
une scénographie aussi étrange que cela
puisse paraître il avait beaucoup
d'opportunités dans le moscou stalinien
de 1932
bon
couché
[Musique]
coli
dieu
et voici ross ross indé américain arrivé
avec mon père mon père robert are heroes
johnson est arrivé ici en 1932 en tant
qu'exilé politique américain il a joué
dans de nombreux films de différents
studios mosfilm gorki film studios qui
alterne stoner et du kentucky monsieur
quel est votre prénom
tom monsieur quel emploi aviez-vous
j'étais manager chez monsieur shelby
pourrait-il plus joué dans des films
être acteur en amérique à l'époque temps
à l'époque je ne pense pas que j'en
doute
[Musique]
il est né à auburn dans l'alabama
c'était un état très raciste ans inessa
ross fille de l'acteur soviétique robert
roth est né et a grandi en russie et vit
maintenant avec son fils james près de
moscou dans une grande maison de
campagne
james était doué pour les sports à la
fin des années 1980 il a joué pour
l'équipe remplaçante de l'un des clubs
de football les plus populaires du pays
le spartak moscou lors d'un match à
dnepropetrovsk blaise comme l'a fait
jouer pour la première équipe en or et
quand il est rentré sur le terrain il a
été accueilli par un tonnerre
d'applaudissements c'était le premier
garçon à la peau noire dans le football
soviétique
le racisme existe et il en union
soviétique dans mon quartier tout le
monde savait que dire des choses
offensante sur ma couleur de peau et est
une chose dangereuse parce que s'est-il
passé après la chute du rideau de fer
lorsque descendants des afro américains
ont eu l'opportunité de retourner en
amérique
je n'arrivais pas à savoir ce que je
pourrais vraiment faire la barre
d'outils et pourquoi maintenant son
temps plus tard la russie attire-t-elle
à nouveau les afro américains
j'adore bouche keane jour et nuit sur la
chaîne dort dans sa chasse avant qui
sait parler silva à gauche donc il
chantonne et à droite il conte des
histoires
on me demande souvent si j'ai été
confronté au racisme en ligne ont sévi
sic
bien sûr tout est dans la russie
d'aujourd'hui vous auriez du mal à
trouver quelqu'un qui n'a pas entendu
parler d'elena kanga elle travaille à la
télévision depuis la fin des années 1980
et présente de nombreux talk show
populaire et notamment la première
émission dédiée au sexe sur la
télévision russe
bonsoir messieurs merci beaucoup de nous
rejoindre dans la première édition de
notre émission sur l'amour est le sexy
j'ai été insulté à cause de ma couleur
de peau parce que j'étais différente
quand j'étais enfant on me demandait
souvent pourquoi tu es noir détient les
enfants me demandait ça et je répondais
parce que mon père vient d'afrique et il
disait à temps mais tu es né à moscou où
il fait froid en hiver
tu aurais déjà dû devenir blanche
nous étions tout simplement unique
surprenant il n'y avait pas d'autres
personnes à la peau noire là bas vous
comprenez le père d'emilie à times
djordje steijns a déménagé en urss dans
les années 1930 avec d'autres afro
américains il a choisi de s'installer en
ouzbékistan où il a participé au
développement de l'élevage bovin dans
les kolkhozes soviétique
c'est là qu'est milles via a passé son
enfance l'enfance a été la période la
plus difficile
on nous appelait tout le temps des
grâces je détestais ça mais que pouvais
je faire
après le déménagement à moscou en 1954
c'est évidemment devenu beaucoup plus
facile parce qu'il y avait des arméniens
des ouzbeks et des enfants de plein
d'autres et il y avait une différence
entre le racisme en amérique et racisme
en union soviétique alors qu'un amérique
le racisme faisait partie du système en
union soviétique le racisme a relevé du
quotidien lit mon grand père olivier
golden ni ma grand mère qui a grandi à
tachkent n'ont assisté à des
démonstrations du racisme ils ont eu des
problèmes parce qu'ils étaient
américains
ni mon grand père ni ma grand mère n'ont
été autorisés à rejoindre le parti
communiste soviétique c'était blessant
[Musique]
il savait que le racisme existe et aussi
en europe mais au moins si l'aller à
londres ou à paris
ils pouvaient séjourner dans les
meilleurs hôtels ce n'était pas le cas
en amérique la vie quotidienne d'un afro
américains dans les années 30 était
frustrante
on ne pouvait pas aller dans certaines
parties de la ville et dans certains
magasins
même si on accueilli les noirs dans
certains hôtels où il y avait des
toilettes séparées pour les noirs et
pour les blancs
même chose pour les fontaines à eau et
puis pour les blancs l'eau était de
meilleure qualité
j'y ai pensé plusieurs fois je ne sais
même pas pourquoi davantage d'afro
américains n'ont pas essayé de partir
vers d'autres pays
peut-être que tout simplement
là ne leur venaient pas l'esprit
on
comment le fait d'avoir un nom de
famille inhabituelle et une apparence
inhabituelle a affecté ma vie en russie
c'était particulier mais ce n'est pas
comme si ça avait eu un véritable impact
sur ma vie comme par exemple ne pas être
accepté quelque part ou autorisés à
faire quelque chose ou encore être
écartée ce genre de chose n'est jamais
arrivé à nîmes après l'effondrement de
l'union soviétique les descendants
d'afro américains ont eu l'occasion de
voyager et de voir la patrie de leurs
parents pour la première fois le petit
fils de georgetown ce gueorgui times
faisait partie de ceux qui sont allés
aux états unis au début des années 1990
et ma première impression a été celle de
quelqu'un venant d'arriver d'union
soviétique
vous semblez sens et bien organisée il y
avait de bonnes routes des soins
abordables pour beaucoup de nourriture
dans les magasins y est on pourrait
sortir la nuit acheter une bière
c'était impensable en union soviétique
rapture quand je te parle pas
quoiqu'allégé c'était surprenant de voir
tant de gens à la peau noire
j'ai vu beaucoup de noirs conduire des
voitures chères à fait j'ai vu aussi que
les jeunes noirs étaient assez débridé
ils se comportaient comme les jeunes
voyous chez nous on a stoppé de wana et
j'ai eu l'impression de revenir dans ma
patrie historique
eh bien oui j'ai ressenti quelque chose
comme ça un espèce de frémissement
pensant que c'est la mater la patrie de
mon grand père mais vous n'y êtes pas
rester et je ne suis pas resté pour un
certain nombre de raisons je n'arrivais
pas à comprendre ce que j'allais faire
là bas pourquoi irais je cherchais un
emploi chez mcdonald's alors que j'avais
un diplôme universitaire et puis j'ai
grandi en russie j'avais pour habitude
de fréquenter des gens qui par les
russes qui lisait des livres russe
dostoïevski ningbo staios qu en amérique
ils sont surtout concentrés sur leurs
affaires le côté pratique des choses ce
sont des gens intéressants mais ils sont
différents
mais j'ai senti que les contacts
personnels que j'avais en russie me
tenait trop à coeur donc je suis revenu
ici contrairement à gueorgui times
sa tante emilia times s'est installé aux
états unis est devenue citoyenne
américaine
elle y lit depuis dix ans la raison
c'est que la vie en amérique et
confortable comme on dit mais mon coeur
bien sûr appartient à la russie je ne
comprends pas vraiment la culture
afro-américaine vous savez alors que la
culture russe mais très proches
passaient bien sûr ces dernières années
j'ai vu et entendu parler de tous ces
meurtres d'afro-américains à la
télévision pour les afro américains qui
sont nés à harlem dans des familles
pauvres
il est presque impossible d'évoluer dans
la société en raison d'un manque
d'éducation
nous avons été éduqués ici en union
soviétique et gratuitement en plus on
nous a donné cette opportunité
tout d'abord j'ai fait l'institut de
gestion de moscou j'ai obtenu un mba à
l'académie russe d'économie nationale et
meynard honorera zeste deux diplômes et
bien de fait guy welsch a cette fois été
secoués ficelles nous sommes dans le
bureau de la société dont je suis
actionnaire et président sanha
tomates nous sommes une entreprise de
taille moyenne c'est à dire que notre
chiffre d'affaires et d'un milliard un
milliard de roubles
oui un milliard de roubles quel genre de
voiture avez-vous nous avons vu votre
belle voiture en arrivant une jaguar
j'ai une nièce à moscou francine
pourquoi parler d'elle parce qu'elle est
née à moscou a déménagé aux états unis
avec sa mère et a vécu pratiquement
toute sa vie là bas et maintenant elle a
décidé de revenir en russie
[Musique]
mais pourquoi j'ai pris la décision de
m'installer en russie je voulais quitter
un pays où je faisais face à la
discrimination le racisme au quotidien
aulas
avant nous surmonter tous les problèmes
raciaux des années 1930
non pas du tout si vous regardez les
récents événements tout est très
similaire aux décennies passées il ya
une situation dont je me souviens comme
si c'était hier
acx j'avais demandé de l'aide à la
police c'était une situation d'urgence
et menahem begin
c'est ensuite que je me suis retrouvé
victime trois policiers m'ont attrapée
et m'ont jeté par terre l'inde
j'ai eu des bleus au bras je pensais
qu'ils allaient me tuer je pensais
qu'ils allaient me tirer dessus
c'était des officiers blancs et oise
c'est la pire expérience de ma vie et je
ne veux jamais jamais la revivre
à cannes j'ai été bouleversée parce que
j'ai grandi dans une famille orthodoxe
russe normale et non nous ne sommes pas
des gangsters
on n'a pas d'armes chez nous on n'a pas
de pull à capuche je pensais que la
police était là pour m'aider
pourquoi ne vont-ils pas aidé l'histoire
se répète encore et encore cela n'a pas
été réglée comme mon arrière grand père
georges times a fait face aux
discriminations dans les années 1930
pendant la grande dépression
à l'époque du mouvement des droits
civiques maintenant c'est la même chose
c'est simplement une version différente
l'union
[Musique]
je vis à moscou depuis un an précisément
à janssen l'anglais je suis professeur
je me sens libre en russie parce qu'ici
peu importe l'heure qu'il est je peux
aller dehors en toute sécurité
[Musique]
un jour nous étions près du métro assis
sur un banc je me souviens des policiers
deux policiers marché vers le haut mon
coeur s'est mis à battre très vite boum
boum boum boum
pourquoi parce que vous savez en
amérique quand vous voyez la police vous
comprenez que vous êtes tout petit c'est
traumatisant
j'ai dit olga tu peux leur parler
j'avais peur elle leur a dit que son ami
venait de déménager d'amérique et que
j'étais russe et le policier a dit ah
bon cinq minutes plus tard ce même
policier bienvenue avec un grand bouquet
de fleurs quelqu'un que je ne
connaissais pas et il m'a dit bienvenue
en russie tu es ici chez toi c'est chez
moi c'est une partie de moi et plus je
vise ici plus je m'en rends compte à
esteban ahmad je ne vais nulle part les
russes que je rencontre ici me
perçoivent d'abord comme une étrangère
mais quand je leur parle russie le 10
mai attends attends qui est des nôtres
qui russe
[Musique]
ah ah
mon dieu mon grand-père croyez que le
tennis était un symbole de prospérité
un symbole de succès quelque chose que
les blancs aisée faisait pour leurs
enfants
donc il voulait aussi que son enfant
fasse toutes les choses que les riches
blancs faisait
et à votre avis quels faits quand j'ai
eu mon propre enfant et quand ma fille a
eu cinq ou six ans mais je les remets
prendre des cours de tennis
elle ne voulait pas elle crié je ne veux
pas je ne veux pas et je lui ai dit si
ton grand père a dit qu'il le fallait et
tu le feras août
c'est une question difficile
qu'est ce qui serait arrivé à mon grand
père et à ma grand mère s'il n'était pas
venu en union soviétique
et s'il était resté à new york mais je
peux dire avec certitude que si mon
grand père et ma grand mère me regarde
de là haut ils doivent être très fier de
moi
s'il voit ma vie la vie de ma mère c'est
ici le voit comment ma fille vit
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
ans
nous sommes les enfants de gens de
couleur
nous sommes nés en terre soviétique et
nous sommes heureux d'avoir enfin trouvé
notre patrie nous aimons et chérissons
notre patrie il n'y a pas d'autres
endroits où nous nous sentons aussi
libre à lens et si quelqu'un demande
nous répondrons nous n'avons pas besoin
d'autres amis que le monde entier le
sache
c'est là que nous avons trouvé la
liberté nous sommes les enfants de gens
de couleur sans nous sommes les enfants
du pays soviétiques
[Musique]